hey how you doing thank you very much
you're a great crowd you look great and
I think I know why you're happy the
Supreme Court can you believe it has
started to do the right thing
daca today the president wanted to get
rid of the dreamers act and they shot
him down early in the week the Supreme
Court said if you come out as gay or
transgender you cannot be fired from
your job and all of America said the
same thing
what's a job but that's pretty big that
a biological male can no longer get a
pink slip for wearing one but yeah well
the experts agree this could lead to a
much more inclusive and a diverse
workplace in fact some day they're
thinking maybe even a straight male
flight attendant
no everybody celebrating today a Lindsey
Graham said this was a great day for no
reason at all in other news President
Trump was walking and that made big news
because he was going down a ramp and he
looked like a downer cow trying to get
into a walk-in bathtub started people
talking about whether he's like up to
the job physically mentally I mean he
didn't have a birthday this week he
turned 74 doesn't look a day over a
bombed but yeah they had a big
celebration at the White House of course
they had ice cream and cake and and then
they remembered it was his birthday it's
a more ice cream and cake and the Trump
of course bragging about how robust he
is and I agree
nothing says America's strong like a
painted fat man lifting a cupcake with
two hands but he did some business this
week also of course the president always
busy he signed an executive order on
policing he said he has never been a cop
but he knows what it's like to wrestle
someone who's resisting
Oh cops not a good time to be a cop
people are mad at the cops these days
they're you know they're even retitling
did you see this the old police shows
it's now a car 54 how dare you murder
she committed and law an utter WTF
and finally a little sad news the Oscars
are going to be delayed yes of course
because of the pandemic and they're not
making any movies so they're putting it
off and the Oscars are gonna be in April
now for the first time the committee was
very reasonable they said we just need
more time to not get it right no matter
what we do
you